Dr. Cutters, I'm 67, your old female. I was diagnosed with an enlarged bladder. I have no pain.
They did diagnostic testing and just determined I do not have your
retention. They told me I must have had your retention in the past. My bladder
size is greater than 1,000 milliliters. I went to an alternative doctor and he
suggested it was estrogen dominance. He wants me to apply table spoon of
progestE, a brand name. Every night for two weeks out of the month. The theory is
that if I apply it every day of the month, my liver will start canceling it out.
What do you think and what would you do in my case? I take thyroid meds but I'm
otherwise healthy. So I don't know if this alternative doctor is just following
a protocol that they've used in the past that they've had success within the
past. I do know that in order to find out if you have estrogen dominance, you
should test. A Dutch test is probably the best test on the market right now. Dutch
test is a dry urine hormone test and they test for all the estrogen. The
metabolites in progesterone and antigen metabolites as well. You can see if you
have estrogen dominance or not. I also test for cortisol levels. So ordering the
Dutch test I think would be the right thing to do. So and then you'll know, is there
any harm in taking progesterone? That's what that product I believe is. It's a
topical progesterone. Is there any harm in taking that? Probably not. So if you have
confidence in that doctor in the way that that doctor here she tested her, I don't
think that there's necessarily any harm in doing that. With somebody your age, most
people have low progesterone at 67 years old. I don't think there's harm in doing
that. But I do think it's wise to get tested. So if that doctor will test, you can order
test. If you're a course member, I don't know if this person is one of our
course members. But if you are on our chronic disease autoimmune course or any of
our other courses, you can run labs through them and it would be the Dutch
complete test that I would record.